and as we talk about vaccines it's week
two of the vacs nevada days raffle
more money and prizes are on the line as
the state tries to encourage more
nevadans to get the shot
it all kicked off last week with the
north las vegas kindergarten teacher
taking home a check for a quarter
million dollars others won 50 and 25
grand and tuition prizes for students
after last week's drawing we were
flooded with phone calls and emails from
you out there worried that you weren't
entered even though you got the vaccine
so we put that question to the governor
this week
everyone who was vaccinated is entered
in the drawing
unless you are a myself
zach our kids you know that sort of
thing spouses
but uh nevada residents who've gotten
the vaccine are entered
into it so tonight's drawing happens at
lake tahoe nevada state park and so
here's a look at the prizes there's one
fifty thousand dollar cash prize
several other small prizes along with
fishing licenses annual park passes
and tuition credits